sarah's with us in boston hi sarah
welcome to the ramsey show what's up
hi dave thanks for having me it's a
pleasure to be on the show today
i'm honored to speak with you ma'am how
can i help
yeah so a little bit about myself i'm 27
years old um i do have a degree
i did have the luxury of my parents
paying for that degree
and i do have i don't have any debt
awesome
so definitely a blessing yes i also
i also have about 60 000 saved
um in my savings account good for you um
thank you and i have a very good job a
very stable job so
um my question for you is i have
actually not invested any of my money so
it's just kind of sitting in my bank
account
um that's including like anything for
retirement
uh so pretty much no investment
whatsoever
um so my question for you i guess it too
um so
how do you suggest i start investing my
money would it be
with a portion of what i've already
saved within that 60 000
range or do you think i should start
investing 15
of all future um i guess paychecks
because i know from your baby steps uh
15 is what you recommend yes ma'am what
do you mean
uh so i make about a hundred thousand
dollars a year good for you
well done what do you do for a living um
i work in software sales
good so oh you got a great future and a
great career yeah you're rocking it
kiddo
excellent okay so what i am going to do
is just go back to those baby steps
of that 60 000 we need to set aside
three to six months of expenses
in a separate account for your emergency
fund
i'm gonna pick a number and just call
that 20 grand just for discussion
purposes you can decide what it is later
okay
okay but that's over there just for when
it rains and kid oh it will rain someday
okay oh i know well yeah so we're going
to set that aside say pandemic yeah it
can happen i mean things can happen so
we're going to set aside an emergency
fund now i got 40 000 and then we answer
your question with that okay
we move on to baby step four which is
fifteen percent of your income going
into retirement which is fifteen
thousand dollars a year and you're
making a hundred grand at 27.
if you only do that the rest of your
life and never get a raise which would
make you a loser
if you never get a raise in your whole
life you'll be a loser would you agree
with that
i agree okay so yeah so if you only
invest 15 000
a year in good growth stock mutual funds
in your 401k with a match or without
imagine roth ira
or roth 401k you will have tens of
millions of dollars
when you get to 65. yeah so you're so so
you're set
if you just play through and don't screw
this up and marry some guy doesn't want
to work or something you know that kind
of stuff right
so you got you got this going on i'm so
proud of you you're doing so good
now once we said that then that leaves
us 40 grand do we need that to become
wealthy no we just established that we
don't and so i'm going to use that as
your down payment on your first home
even if you're not ready to buy a home
right now we'll just keep piling it on
there
above the 15 and we call that baby step
3b
where we're saving for a house but
you've already done it
so uh whenever you get ready to buy a
house you'll have 40 or however much
more you add to that
not counting the fact that you're
putting 15 000 aside because you're very
frugal you make a lot of money but
you're very frugal and careful with your
money you've done a great job you are
your parent's child
they did a great job saving money so you
don't have debt
yes exactly that was my that was my next
question to uh to see if it would be
smart to
um to put the rest of that money into
real estate no i think it'd be
wonderful for your first property that
you live in
and a 15-year fixed rate on the mortgage
where the payment's no more
than a fourth of your take-home pay and
there's no hurry
you could do that next year you could do
that in two years
you're 27 you've got time
you can do this don't panic everybody
gets house fever
and house fever causes your brain to
quit working
and then you buy something you shouldn't
buy and you pay what you shouldn't pay
and then you call me up later and go i
can't believe i did that well
just don't get house fever if you get a
house people take a long cold shower it
will wash it off
just calm down